this morning Twitter went down for
almost an hour yeah
as a result President Trump was forced
to open a window and start yelling at
people on the street hey you want the
Hat no collusion how else is going I was
reported today that President Trump has
been pushing for women's health programs
that are based on abstinence yeah
Trump said it was actually my wife's
idea
earlier today former NF you saw her
earlier today former porn star stormy
Daniels appeared on the view yeah stormy
said this is weird I'm not used to being
watched by millions of women so it's
good enough thank you fine what else is
going on in the nation there's talk of
legalizing marijuana in Utah
[Applause]
however Mormons are worried that
marijuana may be a gateway drug to
coffee so we got some Mormons here
tonight an 18 year old has started a
GoFundMe page so he can achieve his
dream of taking a bath in KFC gravy
that's his dream yeah so far most of his
donations have been provided by the make
a sad Wish Foundation no no no you were
right that's one where you hear this
setup to the joke you're like that's
pretty funny and then you're the joke
like oh you didn't need that
we were good Conan we were good the
Louisiana State Senate has passed a ban
on sex with animals by a vote of 25 to
10 yes the exact vote was 25 nays 210
Moo's so thank you
I'm proud of myself all right
you